jacques attali essayiste économistes est
l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir merci
d'être ici avec nous alors que se met en
place donc la nouvelle alternance de
gauche à l'elysée
vous vous avez été associé de très près
aux changements de 1981 et 31 ans plus
tard
pas d'état de grâce pour le retour de la
gauche avec françois hollande que vous
avez il faut le dire
le premier est tout seul à l'époque fait
entrer à l'élysée donc sous françois
mitterrand les épreuves et les défis
économiques sont graves on le sait
nombreux
hervé hasquin de l' agence france-presse
vous interrogera dans un instant sur
l'europe l'euro et la question de la
croissance
et puis perrine tarneaud de public sénat
cherchera notamment à percer votre
double amitié pour le président élu et
puis le président battu qui vous a fait
voter donc pour le premier est accepté
on leur enlevait d'émission pour le
second lors du quinquennat qui s'achève
est ce là un grand écart vous nous direz
tout à l'heure sachez que nous sommes
également associé avec tivi tchèque une
application d'orange qui permet aux
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent et de
réagir en direct à cette émission
également à poser leurs questions
1981 2012 jacques attali on a
l'impression que la comparaison ne tient
pas elle tient quand même c'est un
président de gauche élu
c'est la bastille et c'est bon j'ai
raison que ça ne tient pas pour des tas
de raisons l'environnement
géostratégique est complètement
différent il n'y a pas d'union
soviétique
l'europe est beaucoup plus intégré il y
a aussi des changements majeurs c'est
que le président de république a
beaucoup beaucoup moins de pouvoir
aujourd'hui qu'il en avait à l'époque et
eon ce soit l'oea dans la nature des
programmes puisque le programme de
françois hollande contient beaucoup
moins la forme de structures majeures
que celle de france celui de françois
mitterrand 1981 et puis c'est toujours
pareil dans la ville dont beaucoup de
dimension la deuxième fois c'est moi
j'existe heures que la famille et vous
avez noté comme moi peut-être même dès
dimanche soir à la bastille l'opinion de
gauche qui a voté hollande ne s'attend
pas à des miracles
elle espère semble-t-il avant tout
qu'ils tiennent bon face aux épreuves
oui encore une fois là le monde est
totalement différent les français ont
maintenant compris je crois que vous
peuvent rien tout seul et que tout va se
jouer sur votre capacité à réussir
l'europe nouvelle phase de l'intégration
européenne et que si on ne réussit pas
eh bien ce qui nous attend c'est
certainement un lent explosion de
l'ensemble européen et dont nous serons
parmi d'autres les victimes le chemin
nous sommes une sorte de no man's land
nous sommes sortis de la tranchée
nationale pas entrer encore dans la
tranchée suivante de l'europe et c'est
normal dans des shows très dangereux
vient alors le président élu a quand
même encore beaucoup de pouvoir une
influence bien sûr dans le cadre
européen jacques attali sans expérience
ministérielle sans pratique de l'état
comme c'est le cas de françois hollande
est ce que ce sera plus dur
devant c'est inexact françois et landes
république appelait de françois hollande
il connaît donc le collaborateur de
la campagne de 1981 il a été ensuite à
l'elysée en mai 81 il a été avec moi ce
conseiller conseiller oui et non mais il
était associé détails des discussions ou
de toute nature pendant plus de deux ans
donc on ne peut pas dire qu'il ne
connaît rien moi je te l'état tout de
suite il a vu comment il a participé au
delà des missions très importantes de
des deux premières années qui inquiète
les deux années les plus difficiles et
nous sommes arrivés tous françois
hollande comme moi même et comme
françois mitterrand qu'il n'avait pas
été mis depuis 26 ans 27 ans ono aux
affaires et puis s'il n'y a qu'en france
qu'on se pose cette question c'est est
venu j'ai vraiment l'âme aucune
responsabilité en angleterre mais c'est
calme en avait aucune
la france est le seul pays où pour être
secrétaire d'état à l'agriculture il va
il fallait être sous secrétaires d'état
les sujets d'interrogation selon vous
néanmoins le voilà d'un coup d'un seul à
57 ans confronté à la solitude du
pouvoir ça chez nous oui c'est vrai et
c'est souvent une question parce que
c'est un homme qui a l'habitude de
gouverner de façon collective qui va
certainement composer même temps
beaucoup du jeu parce qu on a beaucoup
dit savoir qui commence à l'aimer c'est
quelqu'un est composée n'est pas
forcément un mal
le maître mot franc qui le caractérise
c'est l'empathie cherche à comprendre le
point de vue de l'empathie c'est pas la
sympathie c'est la volonté de comprendre
l'autre et faut que tu as compris
l'autre essayé de transformer des
adversaires on a lié ce je crois que
c'est maman faut trancher et c'est clair
que là par exemple il a cette semaine
des décisions très importantes à prendre
à ses emails qui envahit revenus envie
revenir néanmoins s'interroger sur le
style également que va prendre sa
présidence à ce que ça mystère pour vous
là aujourd'hui
donc je pense que lance un nouveau la
meilleure je pense que ce sera une
présidence 13 transparente très obsédé
par la simplicité
il est en même temps par le prestige de
la fonction
donc il va y avoir la foi de la
simplicité et du prestige c'est un du
style et du rythme de la rigueur par il
sera le dernier à monter les marches
lisez en short avec une crise qui
dépasse quoi voilà je suivais la
simplicité si loin de nos codes
monarchique
non non la simplicité c'est pas la
vulgarité justement la simplicité c'est
beau c'est le fait d'être de rester soi
même de ne pas employer des mots
excessifs pour désigner ce qu'on essaie
de ne pas retourner un décorum excessive
mais en même temps le prestige la
distance son droit très important et
risque de vivre hors les murs de
l'elysée puis ce moment du prêt de cette
envie là c'est une volonté de sa
campagne aussi dit-on important c'est
comme ça je ne suis pas son porte parole
jean où je vous en pensez quoi
je pense que c'est pas un homme à se
laisser enfermer que ce soit de toute ma
vie si jamais laissé enfermer au bout
que ce comédien au dit qu'il a bien sûr
été confronté à l'exercice de l'état à
l'elysée d'abord avec vous je rappelle
que vous l'aviez fait venir à l'elysée
avec ségolène royal jeunes sénart qui
s'étaient portés volontaires n'étaient
pas si nombreux en vue de l'élection de
françois mitterrand après tellement
brillant que parmi les mille et un
candidat c'est une chirurgie alors oui
là et puis tellement brillant qu'il
était reconnue assez vite par françois
hollande vous le lancez vous le raconter
par françois mitterrand qui avait noté
la pertinence de ces notes mais on ne
l'a jamais nommé ministre et françois
hollande dit c'est sans doute que
françois mitterrand a voulu me préserver
en quelques sortes les scellés ces deux
modes image d'un homme
je pense que tu as fait c'est vrai ou
faux j'ai écrit déjà plusieurs fois
cette phrase que qui est un peu sévère
mais au fond quel est l'avenir d'un
ministre c'est d'être ancien ministre et
il ya beaucoup d'anciens ministres et
bien françois hollande ne sera jamais
ancien ministre est-ce que sa cordialité
sa gentillesse c'est effectivement
peuvent le protégé de l'esprit de cour
qui finit toujours par s'installer à
l'elysée lundi n'a guère soulevé oui
c'était quelqu'un de stock monsieur
public extrêmement lucide il a
chacun 50 humour et la capacité d'auto
d'origine très fort il a dit que moi
j'avais remarqué ça tout de suite
on l'aurait vu n'est pas la fois une
capacité de se voir d'autres à
l'extérieur de lui-même de se regarder
une certaine distance sur les choses qui
le protège de ça il réussit ce tour de
force d'être à la fois très très gentil
et très méfiants et je pense que c'est
une grande qualité et son sens d'oublier
on parle là que de qualité subjective
c'est quelqu'un de très intelligent très
exceptionnellement intelligente
extrêmement compétents cela pour ça je
l'avais pris avec moi qui apprend très
vite et qui n'a pas de parti pris
idéologique et a priori sauf la justice
sociale la transparence la démocratie
afin d europe des valeurs et leur en
europe très important des deux valeurs
de passe juste la justice sociale et
l'europe
est-ce que la fonction suprême peut
s'accommoder de son humour
selon vous risque de paraître léger
n'aurai peut s'accommoder de vous l'un
peut s'accommoder du bourrin et chaque
aux poudres autre vient du mot shoah
cette photo qui nous rassemble sur sept
en effet il est là c'était un jour de
tout début de la campagne
notre arrivée au pouvoir en 1981 ça fait
sourire évidemment évidemment beaucoup
de souvenirs le choix du premier
ministre la première décision attendue
de françois hollande est ce que vous
êtes plus martine aubry ou jean marc
ayrault ou valls et je dois faire et pas
commenter cela je suis recherché
commenté à celui qui a peut-être
quelques intérêts comme est mon point de
vue il a déjà commencé lentement à vous
je ne vous engage la question paraît pas
davantage françois hollande on le sait à
une référence françois mitterrand et il
s'est mis dans ses pas durant la
campagne
alors peut-être même jusqu'à une
certaine superstition mais le mot roi de
1981 n'existe pas aujourd'hui vous êtes
d'accord il n'est plus question de
redistribuer d'emblée sur ce type de
gomme j'ai dit à plusieurs reprises
oui on me faisant faire beaucoup
d'ennemis enfin quelques ennemis qui
sont pas très nombreux que pierrot avec
une meilleure premier de françois lutter
je crois qu'il a été le meilleur premier
ministre de françois mitterrand c'est
tout un homme c'est un homme tout à fait
remarquable extrêmement sérieux et la
redistribution n'était pas le coeur du
projet de 1981 puisqu'on vous le dit
tout à l'heure en 1981 le coeur
vous êtes aidez à vendre le structurent
les télévisions et radios libres
l'abolition d'un pleinement la
distanciation les lois auroux sur les
conditions de travail la paix sont
incertains toute une série de choses qui
n'ont jamais été remises en cours et
donc s'agissait pas de dépenses
il ya eu des dépenses qui a arrêté en 83
parce qu'on pouvait plus la forme de
structures n'ont pas n'ont pas été
remises en cause et pierre mauroy à
l'angle de cela et même quand en 1983 il
s'est agi d'arrêter les dépenses sans
remettre en cause un vampire mans a été
magnifique et c est celui qui a dit un
tout petit nombre de gens à françois
mitterrand qu'on pouvait pas sortir de
l'europe et françois mitterrand à
écouter pierre mauroy et ce très rare
qu'ils étaient de son avis donc
fièrement est un très grand premier est
aujourd'hui le rôle du premier ministre
c'est à la fois d'exécuter la politique
définie par le président d' assumer
d'avoir une majorité parlementaire et en
même temps d'être capable de dire non
aux pressions du public
nous sommes très importantes pour qu'on
m'explique trois petites questions par
rapport au projet le présidentielle de
françois main d'épicés promesse de coup
de pouce pour le smic est posée smic
c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise idée da
pour moi ça dépend beaucoup de ce qu'on
va alors de ce qu'on va découvrir dans
l'audit
si si l'audit nous dit que tout va bien
les pensions pics sont pas
catastrophiques
elles sont dans les clous regarde ça bon
on peut imaginer que ce sera possible
même si comme chacun sait le smic en mai
lamentations des entreprises dont la
connaît mais classique noir est situé
entre par les noms des déficits publics
cc c'est l'hallali avec l'autre et le
l'augmentation de la demande est aussi
très importante pour créer la croissance
nécessaire donc moi je suis pauvre
hausse des salaires oui j'ai écrit prise
que la hausse avait été bonne
ça dépendra de ce que nous dira la cour
des comptes voilà alors la taxation à 75
% des revenus au-delà de 1 million
d'euros elle se fera selon vous et si
oui est ce une bonne mais moi j'ai dit
publiquement que je n'étais pas
favorable cette mesure je pense que
c'est une mesure démagogique de commun
non non je comprends je comprends qu'en
termes de justice sociale il faille
taxer les riches
je préférais pour ma part qu'on taxe ces
verbes
enfin beaucoup les richesses acquises
c'est à dire l'héritage et l'impôt sur
la fortune que les élections justes 900
enfants naturels de françois hollande
qu'il n'a jamais critiqué en fait la
fortune gagnée c'est pas asus pas
françois hollande c'est la france en
général et en france en général on aime
bien les gens riches on déteste les gens
qui s'enrichissent
parce que ça correspond à une tradition
paysanne de la société française qui est
qui est assez claire dans ce pays les
gens qui s'enrichissent et donc moi je
préfère qu'on taxe les héritiers qui
n'ont rien fait pour la voir que les
gens qui par leur travail naturellement
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya des présidents
de grandes sociétés qui ont des salaires
qu'on peut presque qualifiés d'excessifs
mais aussi ce qui crée une entreprise la
développe et seront taxés à aux trois
quarts de la l'accumulation de richesse
je suis pas d'accord non d'accord avant
enfin sur la retraite à 60 ans avec le
retour partiel pour ceux qui ont
commencé très tôt bonne ou mauvaise idée
don de redonner européen dans la
coulisse l'encontre de cela dans la
commission non non dans les commerciaux
que j'avais président et nous avions dit
que cette réforme était tout à fait
nécessaire celle que françois hollande
propose parce qu'en fait il s'agit
qu'une mesure de justice sociale qui
fait que tout le monde reste à 42 ans et
pas du tout en retour à 60 ans et
souvent ne met pas écrit comme ça c'est
au reste à 42 ans
mais ceux qui ont atteint 42 ans de
cotisations avant parce qu'ils ont
commencé à travailler tôt et ça concerne
150 mille personnes donc c'est pas un
produit c'est inné il est clair que de
toute façon en raison grâce à
l'augmentation de l'espérance de vie
dans le mandat de
françois hollande il va falloir aller
plus loin dans l'augmentation de la
durée de cotisation cotisations 16 qui
l'avait laissé entendre lors du grand
débat sur la réforme de la retraite elle
soutient que sa tante quand même ça
c'était une diva allongement de la durée
1 c'est une conclusion de la commission
que je préside et elle reste valable
voilà cela elle sera appliquée par le
nouveau président espérez-vous dans tous
les cas la nécessité d'agir pour le
nouveau président de la république
français s'impose d'agir vite en raison
des nouvelles craintes pour la zone euro
jacques attali craintes renforcées par
le chaos politique en grèce qui montre
par ailleurs le danger de l'austérité
puisqu'on voit les peuples sans espoir
se tourner vers des extrêmes d'ailleurs
de l'extrême gauche et de l'extrême
droite c'est donc la grèce qui inquiète
les marchés financiers mais en france on
le sait même si on attend là la
conclusions de l'audit de la cour des
comptes le poids de la dette et des
déficits est écrasant à l'heure avant
d'accueillir hervé hasquin de la fp on
voit la situation actualisé par paul
bouffard sait mais finalement la bourse
n'a pas plongé à l'arrivée de françois
hollande
lundi le cac 40 reste dans le vert pas
de mouvements violents
rien à voir avec la chute considérable
de 21% qui avait accueilli françois
mitterrand en 1981 pour le spécialiste
philippe de certines l'alternance
n'était plus peur aux marchés financiers
aujourd'hui la démocratie française on
va dire à l'habitude de l'alternance
même si elle a pas lieu très souvent et
les marchés financiers comprennent
qu'ils vont avoir au pouvoir un certain
nombre de personnes qui ont ont va dire
l'habitude des responsabilités et qui
gèreront la france dans une continuité
politique pendant la campagne à toulon
nicolas sarkozy diabolise françois
hollande et les expériences folle que la
gauche pourrait mener mais au final dans
les salles de marché le nouveau
président en inquiète pas au lendemain
de l'élection le marché est un petit peu
faible à paris surtout sur les marchés
actions en revanche on constate une
relative stabilité sur les marchés
obligataires avec des taux
français qui évoluent assez de façon
assez peu marqué ce qui est plutôt
rassurant
rassurant aussi du côté du taux
d'intérêt au lendemain de la victoire
la france emprunte aux taux de 2,1 pour
cent françois hollande ne l'a pas fait
exploser les marchés étaient prêts
cependant la france reste sous
surveillance
on est un petit peu dans une phase
d'incertitude effectivement en france
jusqu'au résultat bien entendu des
élections j'existe hâtives on verra
vraiment la façon dont laquelle les
choses on se dessiner en france et puis
aussi un certain nombre d'incertitudes
quant aux relations avec avec
l'allemagne désormais l'attention des
places boursières est accaparée par la
grèce il faudra aussi surveiller les
différences de conception de croissance
en zone euro
l'investissement à la française
l'austérité à l'allemande
voilà c'est avec nos confrères hervé
soit jacques attali qui sont jacques
attali oms en constatant une situation
extrêmement compliquée des dés à présent
et un bras de fer entre françois
hollande et angela merkel s'est déjà
engagée alors dans cette affaire sur les
eurobonds sur les investissements face
sur le rachat d'eds de la dette des pays
européens endettés par la bce qui va
devoir céder françois hollande ou angela
merkel
moi je parie pour si on fait un pari
aussi simple que cette question vous
venez poser je parie que l'allemagne va
vite comprendre alors la question c'est
savoir vite c'est quelques semaines ou
quelques mois que c'est son intérêt
absolument vital de construire sept
étages fédéral européen dont les
eurobonds ne sont une des premières
traductions robben que parmi les
premiers la commission que j'ai présidé
il ya quatre ans avait avait proposé
comme une des solutions que de la crise
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui on se
rend compte comme une évidence que
l'euro est une monnaie sans état c'est
la seule monnaie dans le dans le monde
qui n'a pas d'état pour le
le assurez la la légalité des
compétitivité des régions qui partagent
la même mais ça ne peut pas marcher vous
le savez quand on a fait le traité de
maastricht on savait qu'ils avaient une
étage fédéral ensuite et donc la
croissance
on ne peut passer que par cette relance
là mais plus largement la survie de
l'euro passe par cela et les allemands
sont eux mêmes seront les premières
victimes d'une explosion de l'euro si
l'euro monte
ils perdent tout donc en effet y aura un
bras de fer mais aujourd'hui dès
aujourd'hui si vous regardez ce qui se
passe en europe
il ya un vote très favorable les
européens pour l'euro et pour la
croissance et donc c'est plutôt mal à
merkel qui est isolé et pas la position
de la frontière voix vous souhaitez vous
souhaitez que l'europe emprunte à quelle
qu'elles émettent des project bonds on
aime ça oui les obligations là qui
permettent de financer donc des deux
grands projets européens vous souhaitez
ceci l'endettement des états ne vous
suffit pas il faut que l'europe
s'endettent à son tour oui absolument
il faut bien avoir conscience de ce que
l'europe a une chance inouïe c'est que
son étage fédéral n'est pas endetté
c'est un outil que les états unis non
plus puisque l'heure est à venir à les
frais d'enquêté et que le japon n'a pas
parce que l'on est à jeun étatique est
présentée nous l'avons actuellement je
serais très content que cette dette
fédérale consiste simplement à faire du
laxisme de plus mais il ya deux choses
qui vont être absolument nécessaire dans
les six mois qui viennent la première
c'est évidemment de relancer la
croissance par des investissements
structurants il ya au moins deux
domaines c'est les économies d'énergie
puisque l'europe dépend terriblement
d'énergie emporté et les nouvelles
technologies de communication et ça ça
existe d'investissements par an puis un
deuxième chose qu'on oublie dans général
c'est que le système financier européen
et de situations catastrophiques
il lui faut des augmentations de capital
massives
sinon il va être obligé de réduire ses
crédits et donc de réduire la croissance
et il ya ça c'est quand même la spirale
infernale recommence c'est à dire que le
on a déjà expérimenté
laxisme avec les budgets des états
membres aujourd'hui on prend le risque
de ceux de s'embarquer dans une nouvelle
situation difficile à l'échelle
européenne
si on crée de nouveau une date
européenne aux côtés moi il ya 2 dead
très différentes
il ya une mauvaise tête qui consiste à
faire en sorte que à partir du mois de
septembre
nos fonctionnaires soient payés par de
l'emprunt il ya une bonne dette qui
consiste à financer l'investissement
chacun d'entre nous on le sait quand on
s'endette pour acheter un logement c'est
très bien dans les limites de ce qu'on
peut acheter quand on s'endette pour le
crédit à la consommation c'est une
catastrophe
or aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas nous ne
sommes pas donné assez de moyens pour
investir sur l'avenir
là c'est tout ça c'est bien gentil mais
c'est encore nous les allemands qui
allons payer c'est une heure c'est une
erreur de raisonnement que c'est sarkozy
a commis au cours du débat qui prouve et
je permets de dire publiquement que j'en
avais parlé avec lui et je n'ai pas
réussi à le convaincre
c'est une faute de raisonnement total le
les emprunts européens mais absolument
pas financée par les allemands c'est ne
rien comprendre à ce qu'est l'europe
il faut évidemment que cet emprunt soit
garanti est financé par quelque chose
qui sert le service de la dette ce n'est
pas les états nations c'est une
contribution fiscale proprement
européenne qui est irréversiblement
attribué à une entité européenne
l'eurozone ou union européenne et qui
assure le service de cet emprunt
d'investissement et l'allemagne la
france
absolument rien à voir instaurer
garantie c'est l'entité européenne
angela merkel ne veut pas bouger
elle est très ferme est ce que françois
l'on ne peut bouger et sur quoi ce
qu'est ce qui peut apporter lui en
échange éventuel 36 angela merkel bouge
un peu
il faut régler que cette la règle d'or
tout en restant je n'ai pas de deux
je suis une très grande sérénité la
sauvegarde et l'europe aujourd'hui
comment elle et l'europe au geste et le
cas de la grèce qui va très mal c'est
vrai mais le portugal va mal les
refusent
l'espagne nations catastrophique en
particulier son système bancaire
les hollandais n'ont plus gouvernement
et personne ne sait comment l'irlande va
financer ses fins de mois et l'italie
est bloqué parce que les réformes
montanuy donc évidemment il ya une
semaine de paralysie qui est en train de
rejoindre rome et donc on va changer de
cap on va changer de pied et c'est
l'objet de la tribune que j'ai publié
avec pascal amis et quelques autres
européens allemands grecs italiens
espagnols ce soir dans le monde
je pense que ça ira beaucoup plus vite
qu'on ne le croit à un moment je pensais
que madame merkel ne pourrait pas bouger
avant ses propres élections je pense
qu'elle va bouger avant ces élections
alors là on a par rapport à votre
question qu'est-ce que aulas on peut
donner
françois hollande peut donner président
français tout ça c'est une question
purement diplomatique est simple gm
négocie assez d'accord de ce genre pour
le savoir les allemands diront on n'a
pas cédé
le trait est acceptée à oui mais on a
accepté une annexe qui porte la
croissance les eurobonds d'heure les
français diront la renégocier l'alena
protocole juridique à l'ancien sherpa
que que vous avez de françois mitterrand
à couvre cette idée mais c'est passé
c'est plus quand vous négocier un traité
si vous le compléter par un chapitre de
plus pasqua oui c'est ça l'important
l'association c'est permettre à tout le
monde de pouvoir dire qu'ils évacuent
tandis que kent président actuellement
aux finances en allemagne à wolf autant
de chocs bleus il va falloir trouver
quelqu'un pour bercy très rapidement
c'est quoi le profil des candidats
idéals aujourd'hui pro versilia de poste
il ya le poste de ministre des finances
et le poste de ministre budget le bénin
qui devra être monsieur oui un autre qui
doit être monsieur non alors vous avez
des idées je suppose un parce que c'est
un ami proche du président méduses
c'est là où consulter des choses que je
ne parlais qu'avec lui qui me demandait
mon avis oui vous a demandé votre avis
donc je n'en parlerai pas est-ce qu'il a
choisi encore une fois je ne suis pas
son porte parole
les qualités requises pour bercy
aujourd'hui et pour pour ma part pour
que les choses soient claires je ne
participerai pas à aucune fonction
personnel je suis très heureux d'avoir
mon ancien collaborateur de françois
mitterrand devenu président de
république je suis très heureux de
d'applaudir à son succès mais j'en
resterai là alors les qualités pour
bercy aujourd'hui
jodie pour bien vous remercie budget il
faut un monsieur non extrêmement
courageux capable de proposer et
d'exiger des coupes budgétaires très
sévère et pour ce qui est de l'économie
proprement dit il faut quelqu'un qui
soit capable de négocier le basculement
fédéralisme budgétaire l'économie de
croissance et donc ces deux
personnalités complémentaires qu'ils
avaient salué tout à l'heure les
réformes de structure qui avait été
initiée très vite en 1985 en place au
jury qui sont pas encore en place à ce
que vous ne regrettez pas l'absence de
réformes de structure dans le projet de
françois hollande aujourd'hui parce que
vous plaidez dans un sens libéral
jacques attali pour plus de
compétitivité d'ordre une réforme du
marché du travail
paris cent mais ça on ne trouve pas dans
le dans le projet françois lancien aux
libyens la commission que je préside et
qui était encore une fois je rappelle
une commission bipartisane
nous avions proposé une des réformes
fondée sur trois pieds
oui la compétitivité l'investissement et
la justice sociale et le gouvernement
précédent n'a utilisé qu'une partie par
exemple vous parlez de la flexibilité du
marché du travail
nous nous avions dit il faut cette
flexibilité ça a été fait sous la forme
de la réforme que nous avions proposé de
la rupture à l'amiable du contrat de
travail mais nous avions dit surtout ne
faites pas la rupture à l'amiable du
contrat de travail
si vous mettez pas en place
simultanément la sécurisation des
parcours professionnels qui fait
quelqu'un qui perd son contrat de
travail ddt est immédiatement repris en
charge par un nouveau contrat qu'on
avait appelé contrat d'évolution qui
permet de garantir que cette personne
est immédiatement en situation de
formation
voilà donc il faut
à la fois de la justice sociale pour que
la mobilité puisse être acceptée car il
y eut une idée que vous avez lancé la
retraite à la carte en quelque sorte
éventuellement que l'on pourrait prendre
au delà de l'âge légal peut-être à 65
ans c'est une idée que le président élu
est susceptible de reprendre sais pas en
tout cas c'est une idée de bon sens qui
fonctionne très bien dans des pays aussi
différents que la suède et la pologne
que beaucoup de syndicats français en
particulier la cfdt a prouvé que nous
avions étudié dans cette commission et
qui me semble avoir l'avantagé
extraordinaire d'être à la fois
socialement très juste de permettre une
très grande liberté dans le choix de la
retraite est d'avoir les avantages la
fois de la capitalisation et la
répartition donc je pense que c'est le
système idéal pour après 2017 nous aimer
la prospective est ce que vous imaginez
moyen de long terme une alliance entre
les socialistes en france et puis les
centristes notamment françois bayrou qui
a voté personnellement à titre personnel
pour le candidat socialiste la grande
affaire de ce mandat sera peut-on créer
une justice sociale qui ne soit pas un
frein à la réussite donc la discussion
qu'on avait sur impôts sur les revenus
ou impôt sur le patrimoine et la
construction européenne il est clair que
dans la gauche comme dans la droite sur
la construction européenne ya deux
points de vue il ya des gens à gauche
qui sont anti européen il ya des gens à
droite qui sont anti lambert est évident
que l'europe elle-même supposera pour se
construire à la fois de convaincre ceux
de la gauche qui forment la majorité que
et je connais des gens qui étaient
hostiles à la construire européenne va
même à maastricht sont aujourd'hui
favorable au fédéralisme européen
dans la mesure où cette affaire'' liste
de croissance et un est évidemment tous
ceux qui sont ailleurs au centre et qui
ont compris que le fédéralisme est hélas
non pas une utopie idéologique mais la
condition même du maintien du niveau de
vie en france est dans une perspective
encore politiquement se traduire par une
nouvelle alliance
à mon sens après il va se passer
tellement de choses dans les cinq ans
qui viennent il y aura une grande crise
en europe comme il y en a eu en 82 83
quand on est passé de rien n'aura lui
mais elle est là déjà où elle a parlé
d'une autre là
oui je pense que nous sommes dans une
crise larvée
aujourd'hui on voit chaque dimension
chaque pays croire qu'il a encore du
temps on fonctionne au petit peu jusqu'à
maintenant comme monsieur madoff a
fonctionné monsieur madoff a donné du
temps à tout le monde mais aujourd'hui
on fond le dernier qui a donné du temps
c'est monsieur draghi quand il a au
dernier moment moi j'avais dit s'il
n'intervient pas avant noël il y aura le
rôle de l'euro il était intervenu le 23
décembre donc assez ça fait c'est ça qui
est malheureusement briser votre
prédiction selon les événements
heureusement ce n'était pas une
prédiction c'est dur c'était une mise en
garde
searle euro disparaît on a fin d'année
sauf si la banque centrale intervient
avant noël et elle est intervenue le 23
dans la prévision est difficile surtout
quand elle concerne l'avenir
c'était pas si je vous dis un piano va
vous tomber sur la tête et vous vous
écartez vous allez vous moquez de moi ou
de renvoyer votre prédiction est fausse
non ben magnifions était juste c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé lundi
aussi que le sarkozy avait de bonnes
chances d'être élu finalement c'est
françois hollande
ggp a pronostiqué qu'il était certain
gagné jeudi la bataille sera serrée
alors qu'elle quelques l avenir
justement pour la zone euro à court
moyen terme ce père si c'est à dire ce
que je n'ai plus 15 ans il n'y a pas
j'ai s'il n'y a pas un basculement dans
les cinq ans qui viennent un état
fédéral avec un ministre des finances un
budget et des recettes fédérales le rôle
a aucune possibilité de durée ils
disparaîtront et à court terme la grèce
c'est un cauchemar c'est la grèce c'est
un problème difficile si on lui donne
pas davantage de temps elle va sortir et
si elle sort les marchés comme on dit
c'est à dire les prêteurs du on
attendait s'ils sont pas capables de
régler le problème de la grèce ils
régleront pas su n'a pas retenu les
portugal et puis ensuite celui d'italie
donc on est obligé de régler pour le
dégage de lui donner davantage de temps
et on se rendra compte à ce moment là
que donner davantage de temps la grèce à
existe des moyens qu'on n'a pas encore
d'où l'importance de se donner davantage
de ressources en europe à ce que vous
espérez que françois hollande soit le
mario monti français m'avait menti qui a
fait partie de votre commission et qui a
mis en oeuvre en italie ajustement
certaines des recettes que vous
mises en oeuvre mais alors est ce que
vous espérez qu'il le sera le mario
monti mario monti et président du
conseil et président de la république ce
qui crée une différence
gilles mario monti applique
remarquablement lui aussi la partie
droite du rapport et avec beaucoup plus
de d'entêtement que ne l'avait fait les
de courage que vous avez fait le
gouvernement de droite précédents
donc j'espère que je suis sûr d'ailleurs
que nicolas françois hollande attention
non je vais commencer une autre phrase
que françois hollande appliquera toute
la partie que nicolas sarkozy n'ait pas
appliqué et retrouverai la sa fonction
d'homme de synthèse en quelques sortes à
merci hervé hasquin perrine tarneaud de
public sénat arrive pour d'autres
questions avant cela va voir donc avec
tam tran huy je vous le disais tout à
l'heure
ce grand écart supposée entre deux
amitié présidentielle 2007 nicolas
sarkozy fait appel aux lumières de
jacques attali pour libérer la
croissance en pleine stratégie
d'ouverture confié une mission à
l'ancien sherpa de françois mitterrand
c'est un coup de maître nicolas sarkozy
lui adresse finalement un satisfecit
jaber à l'essentiel de vos conclusions
si certains étaient effrayés par le
contenu de vos propositions
moi je les trouve plutôt raisonnable
dans l'essentiel raisonnable dans
l'essentiel même si l'on a appliqué que
la moitié et c'est bien ce que lui a
reproché jacques attali avec fracas sur
son blog l'économiste précise ces
attaques
nicolas sarkozy est responsable de la
perte du triple à et de la hausse du
chômage et n'a su ni réduire la dette
publique ni réformer l'état ni réduire
les privilèges son coeur balance donc du
côté de françois hollande
rien d'étonnant pour celui qui affirme
avoir toujours voté à gauche et surtout
qui a été le mentor du nouveau président
de la république en 1983 hollande et
conseiller à l'elysée et travaille avec
jacques attali
à ses côtés il a même participé à l'un
des coups les plus retentissants de la
mitterrandie le journaliste andré
bercoff raconte elodie est content j'ai
dans mon équipe
un type qui très très bien
il ya travaillé avec toi il s'appelle
françois hollande et donc il me présente
françois hollande qui avait 27 28 ans je
crois à l'époque était bien là est un
peu bébé cadum comme ça très sympa plein
d'humour et puis on commence à
travailler ensemble avec l'aval de
françois mitterrand et de jacques attali
françois hollande et andré bercoff
sortent finalement un pamphlet
soi-disant contre la gauche signé une
catho l'auteur est présenté comme un
ancien dirigeant de la droite c'est
françois hollande qui se charge de la
promotion du livre à la radio le power
société ne tombera pas comme un fruit
mûr et ce qui laisse entendre que nous
pouvons c'était un beau la droite
revenir au pouvoir dans les mois qui
viennent ou même dans les deux années
qui viennent se trompent et trompent les
français
en réalité ce livre et d'un pamphlet
contre la droite sous couvert
d'égratigner la gauche c'est surtout un
livre qui montre qu'être de gauche et
libérale n'est pas contradictoire
ce n'est pas jacques attali qui va lui
ni à la ferc attend et merveilleux quand
même s'en souvenir aujourd'hui bonsoir
perrine tarneaud vous a laissé faire de
drôles de choses à françois hollande à
l'elysée à d'abord je rectifie un petit
peu quelques petites choses avant que
j'ai toujours voté à gauche
j'ai voté pour ségolène royal et quand
nicolas sarkozy en réalité c'est
françois fillon qui m'a demandé de
présider ces conditions on va en parler
après je n'ai accepté qu'à trois
conditions
j'écrivais moi même la lettre qui
m'envoyait je composais moi même la
liste delà des membres de la commission
et j'avais liberté totale de faire le
rapport et nous avons travaillé avec une
commission vous retrouverez les moitiés
de gens de gauche - ses jambes droites
exactement le rapport que j'aurais remis
à simone loria à kizliar toujours le
même jour
le jour même claire oui à un nicolas
sarkozy et c'est pour bien montrer que
tes rapports bi partisme en quatre ans
oui enfin je vais raconter pour la
première fois que je n'ai jamais raconté
vraiment il y avait eu un jour une
situation vraiment très pénible où la
france était le françois mitterrand
était très impopulaire et il me dit
82,83 oui c'était au sommet d'athènes je
souhaite me dit votre ami bercoff
françois mitterrand avait déjà rencontré
chez moi il avait écrit un livre très
qui avaient énormément de succès sous le
pseudonyme de philippe de comines où il
racontait les 180 jours de migrants
avant l'élection il pourrait faire un
autre livre comme ça ce serait bien et
je dirais à coudre et tu pourrais
refaire un philippe de commynes pour
mettre des bâtons dans les roues de la
droite non c'était l'idée attendait
c'était l'idée de faire un livre comme
quelqu'un de gauche qui parlait contre
la droite dans l'est dans l'esprit de ce
que j'ai dit andré c'est andré bercoff
l'idée de faire à l'envers c'est à dire
de faire un livre d'un homme de droite
amer contre cette droite idiote qui
n'arrive pas à répondre à la gauche
était une idée très subtil et françois
hollande s'est préservé alors
en fait c'est andré qui a écrit le livre
et il a fallu faire en sorte que cdd
vous voudrez à écrire ce livre non un
collaborateur de l'époque extrêmement
brillant passé quelques documents à
andré bercoff pour écrire ça s'est
arrêté là on l'a vu c'était le service
après vente et donc une mystification et
certains à droite lui reproche
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
perrine oui on a vu valérie rosso debord
qui est encore réagi la lors de
l'élection de françois hollande
en parlant de kouba de manipulation et
en disant battant des symboles est jugé
non c'est d'abord c'est moi qui porte
l'entière responsabilité de cette sphère
c'est moi qui lui ai demandé de le faire
même si c'était très surpris de ce que
l'on dresse bercoff passe à la radio
avec françois hollande je ne savais pas
ce jour là et qu andré bercoff s'est
ensuite des volées
donc là je sais c'est une petite canular
sans importance mais elle l'a rappelé
tout à l'heure vous avez commencé à
travailler avec françois hollande et
ségolène royal ils sont venus tous les
deux se présentait à vous avant même
l'élection de françois mitterrand à
l'elysée un moment où tous les hauts
fonctionnaires les plus tôt travaillé
avec michel rocard cdu qui était plus
populaire à gauche à l'époque qui était
le plus politique des deux entre
françois hollande et ségolène royal
j'ai très différents mais si j'avais
répondre simplement giresse était
ségolène royal qui était la plus la plus
engagée la plus exigeante la plus
rigoureuse la plus formelle dans ses
valeurs lefrançois était extrêmement
subtile extrêmement intelligent beaucoup
moins démonstratif dans ses affirmations
de ces valeurs vous le voyez pas à
l'époque forcément faire une carrière
politique si je voyais quelqu'un qui
avait très envie de faire une carrière
politique mais quelle c'est quelqu'un
qui a toujours la distance à l'égard du
tout et y compris à l'égard de lui même
douloureux le fait qu'ils peuvent faire
des choses et cette distance me faisait
penser j'ai d'ailleurs dit à plusieurs
reprises que si on avait un des deux qui
pourrait abandonner la coop la politique
c'est plutôt lui qu'elle ce qui veut
dire que la ville a aussi avancé masqué
on peut tromper
sur les personnalités sur les avenues
veut dire je ne suis pas trop trompé
puisque deux assistants sont devenus que
c'est vrai vous avez dit tout à l'heure
qui n'étaient pas si nombreux jeunes art
à ce moment là oui mais quand après
l'élection de françois mitterrand
françois mitterrand m'a demandé de
constituer mon équipe je vous assure que
la jav est vraiment là sur l'arrêté ici
d'avoir un couple vous y travaillez à
l'origine je les ai pris non pas parce
qu'ils forment un couple j'étais dans
les fonctions très différentes mais j'ai
trouvé très bon tous les deux et et je
prie l'autre puisqu'ils n'étaient pas
les seuls allez moi il y avait jean
louis bianco pierre morel et toute une
série d'autres qui sont 15 ans rejoint
françois hollande pour sa campagne s'est
beaucoup inspirée de celle de françois
mitterrand en 80 notamment sur la
gestuelle aussi sur des thématiques dans
ses discours
ça vous a beaucoup marqué cet emprunt
françois hollande comment vous l'avez
évidemment on ne sait pas le seul à
gauche à faire ça si on regarde et
laurent fabius c'est aussi
incroyablement proche de françois
mitterrand
enfin vu ce que j'ai d'ailleurs si je
peux me permettre ce travail personnel
aussi fait en train politique puisque on
m'avait proposé la circonscription que
je n'ai pas voulu prendre parce que je
voulais pas faire ce genre de calle avec
c'est moi qui lui est sous traitée si
j'ose dire la construction de 200 de san
martin qui l'a acquise a finalement pris
donc il ya beaucoup de jours à gauche
qui reprennent ce genre d'image mais
j'étais quand même assez frappant
pendant la campagne oui oui c'était
assez frappant mais je pense que ça
correspond aussi à une attitude
d'orateur sait avec quelle ressemblance
vous voyez vous entre les deux
présidents socialistes de la vème
république le guen je pense que françois
hollande va être quelqu'un d'aussi
distant secret ferme autoritaire que
françois mitterrand
je pense qu'il aura sa donc les bons et
les mauvais côtés vous savez françois de
le ligoter sont nécessaires quand nous
avons été au premier sommet de françois
mitterrand je raconte des souvenirs
d'anciens combattants ils sont premier
sommet européen c'est à luxembourg on
est rentré de l'avion dans l'anus et à
semer s'est très mal passé j'ai dit à
françois noguères au fond pour vous
c'est quoi la principale qualité d'un
chef d'état et il avait parait funds
réfléchi longtemps il m'avait dit je
voulais vous répondre le courage mais
c'est l'indifférence et une cette
qualité là je crois que françois
hollande est capable de l'avoir ski
espinola pas naturellement parce que
c'est un homme profondément empathique
n'est pas sympathique mais en pâtit il
cherche à comprendre l'autre mais il a
très bien compris je pense que là où il
est il va falloir vraiment assumé la
solitude ce qui explique aussi un peu
son attitude lors de cette phase de
transition où il s'affiche au travail
continue à mener la même vie qu'avant
c'est obligatoire là cette modestie de
figer cette modestie ou c'est pour
vraiment qui vais avec nicolas sarkozy
la france est joué il connut
merveilleusement bien la france j'ai un
peu et parfois je pense que s'il n'a pas
beaucoup voyagé alain dans le monde
c'est parce qu'il a voyagé tellement
dans dans la france et dans les gens il
aime beaucoup voyager l'inter des gens
plus que voyager à l'inter des espaces
et cette connaissance qu'il a des gens
aiment vraiment profondément à penser
que la france a envie de sérénité de
tranquillité envie d'antagonisme il va
tout faire à mon sens fait je passe pour
paroles je regardais en extérieur pour
pour apaiser la france est ce que vous
êtes indécis du sarkozysme aujourd'hui
j'ai jamais été sarkozyste jamais été
mais c'est vraiment positif plutôt
confiant un certain moment sur le
volontarisme
oui et j'ai écrit récemment une lettre à
un ami droite où j'ai dit que jusqu'au
dernier moment c'est jusqu'où trois
derniers mois
je pensais qu'il ferait penser qu'il
serait réélu et je pensais qu'il ferait
une campagne de droite libérale j'ai été
très très très très choquée de ses choix
de fin de campagne et j'étais
extrêmement déçu que sur la ligne
patrick buisson il sur le flirt avec les
idées d'extrême droite sur le fait
qu'ils reparlent la rupture de chaîne
retour des frontières enfin de tout
l'abomination de la droite anti
européenne ce qui a fait perdre à cette
stratégie
j'espère que c'est ça qui l'a fait
perdre ou est-ce que ça a limité sa
défaite parce que c'est une défaite
honorable
j'espère que c'est j'espère plutôt que
la droite tire halal sans que c'est ça
qui l'a fait perdre et que l'école
buissonnière et sera qu'une comme on dit
pour l'école buissonnière en général le
king parenthèses
est-ce que vous placez au même niveau
votre amitié pour nicolas sarkozy et
celle pour françois hollande je vous
savez on peut avoir des amis pour qui on
ne vote pas bien sûr mais je dois celle
ci est ce que c'est le même la même
amitié va passer même nom vont longer
une connivence une complicité d'une
histoire partagée de valeur avec
françois hollande qui n'a rien à voir
avec celle que j'ai avec nicolas sarkozy
pour qui j'ai et j'avais j'ai encore
malgré cette parenthèse qui m'a beaucoup
choqué la grande annie une grande grande
amitié
vous croyez vraiment qu'il va arrêter la
politique ah oui je pense je pensais que
ce n'est pas revenue un sorte de
paroxysme je pense qu'il va arrêter
j'espère qu'il va trouver un autre
complice mans parce que l'exemple du
destin de monsieur n'est pas convaincant
prochaine étape politique ce sont les
élections législatives ont peut-être
andy ram ans pour l'instant les sondages
montrent que le ps et l'ump sont plutôt
coude à coude est ce que vous pensez
vraiment que les français pourraient
souhaiter une cohabitation
parce qu'avec certains s'engagent
l'argument que juge avait écrit ça il ya
quelques mois d'ailleurs que je voyais
la droite utiliser le plus efficacement
ses ne donnait pas tous les pouvoirs
gauche le sénat les régions les
départements et arguments extrêmement
forte
l'argument inverse vous n'allez quand
même pas paralyser la france et savourer
vie l'argument le plus fort ne paralyse
et pas la france au moment de cette
crise ce serait effrayant et je pense
que les français qui ont beaucoup de bon
sens vont donner les moyens au président
mais vous croyez par exemple à l'idée
défendue pendant la campagne par
françois bâillon d'un gouvernement
d'union nationale
pas maintenant non non il faut que la
gauche ait les moyens de gouverner
si la crise comme je le crois dans les
2-3 ans est un paroxysme qui exigera de
2,2
faire un saut métaphysique vers l'europe
fédérale alors que bien des choses sont
possibles
est-ce que vous pensez que le parti
socialiste a raison de vouloir préserver
françois bayrou lors de sa tentative de
retrouver son siège de député dans les
pyrénées atlantiques j'avais créé un
pôle affiche développer candidat
président je voudrais bien dépité rester
député
oui moi je parle avec l'aide du pse et à
ma connaissance même si je ne suis pas
du tout mêlé à ça ceci n'a pas été
négocié avant mais je trouve que c'est
une marque d'élégance ont voté
aujourd'hui leur entrée au gouvernement
tant pis si les centrales nucléaires ne
sont pas fermées à ma connaissance notre
gouvernement ne dépend pas d'eux mais du
palissandre la publient leurs
engagements est ce que l'un des enjeux
du quinquennat 2 françois hollande selon
vous est de faire baisser le front
national sauf à vouloir enfermer la
droite
évidemment dans le piège de l'extrême
droite une arrière-pensée toujours
possible oui on peut on peut toujours
penser ça mais dans la mesure où la
gauche a toujours voulu la
proportionnelle on va l'accuser de de
cristalliser l'entrée de l'extérieur on
l'espère at on n'a pas le fera pas
baisser artificiellement la fera baisser
par l'intégration par l'affirmation que
l'immigration n'est pas une mauvaise
chose mais au contraire c'est la chance
de la france par de la pédagogie pas par
des pas par des batailles sur tv5 a peur
de réagir via twitter on à eric qui nous
demande qui sera le jacques attali de
françois hollande
je crois que dans chaque période il ya
des gens différents qui vont s'installer
mais à ma connaissance le rôle que j'ai
rempli qui n'a pas été remplie sous
jacques chirac ni sous nicolas sarkozy
puisque le titre de conseiller spécial a
été donnée à monsieur guaino mais qu'ils
en aient qu'il faisait pas du tout de la
même chose que mon lancer de la plus du
tout la même chose
l'histoire a fait que françois hollande
n'a pas été accompagnée par quelqu'un
dans dans cette période préalable du
genre que ge était indépendant
intellectuelle libre mais en même temps
proche de l'homme politique et je pense
qu'il y aura d'autres figures
exceptionnelles dont j'en connais
certains tout à fait brillant très
exceptionnelles qui seront auprès de
solange mais dans d'autres fonctions
l'ultime question on avait par exemple
sur notre plateau il ya soir à killeen
au moral il avait sous le bras le
discours d'investiture de françois
mitterrand en 81 quelle idée ils
pourraient puiser dans ce discours
d'investiture si vous imagine que vous
en souvenez un petit peu déjà vu
beaucoup de phrases du discours de de
château chinon et c'est un nom je pense
que les valeurs sont là et françois
mitterrand savait si je peux me terminé
par ailleurs marc personnes il me manque
tous les jours c'était pas comme mon
père j'ai une immense passion pour mon
père mais c'est quelqu'un qui a été plus
présent une telle force
une tel ou tel génie à la fois
intellectuelle et culturelle la plus
unique que tous ceux qui l'ont connu il
manquait donc tous ceux qui n'ont pas
connu il ya aussi du regret merci
giocatelli d'oeuvre est avec nous ce
soir merci pèlerine bonsoir à tous et à
très vite
comment la série peut-elle s'extirper de
l'engrenage de la violence
bachar ne pourra pas faire taire la
société syrienne à l'heure d'internet il
ne peut plus empêcher l'opposition de
parler pour comprendre les enjeux de ce
drame politique et humain ce
documentaire des mails les rouages du
système mis en place par le clan assad
de père en fils d'hafez à bachar hafez
el-assad pouvait emprisonné pendant
vingt ans les gens sans que personne
n'en sache rien cela n'est plus possible
aujourd'hui
le fait que cela dure depuis si
longtemps cela ne veut pas dire que la
population accepte tout cela ou qu'elles
s'y est habitué le crépuscule des assad
samedi à 22h sur public sénat
oh
ap
bonjour cet effet nous sommes en corse
pour parler d'un sujet important la
préservation des forêts et donc de la
biodiversité
vous le savez les arbres sont le poumon
de la planète ici il recouvre presque la
moitié des terres mais aujourd'hui les
menaces sont nombreuses
incendie urbanisation exploitations
agricoles et même des insectes
alors comment préserver et entretenir
ces quatre cent mille hectares de pins
de chênes d'oliviers et de châtaigniers
c'est ce que nous allons voir dans ce
nouveau numéro des pieds sur terre il
faudrait concentre l'essentiel de la
biodiversité végétale et animale de la
planète pourtant chaque année ce sont 6
millions et demi l'hectare qui
disparaissent en cause l'exploitation
humaine bien sûr mais aussi les
incendies qui dévastent le sud de la
france
il est l'arbre de l'année 2011
sous ce feuillage se cache un pistachier
vieux de mille ans à ghisonaccia sur la
côte est c'est arbres hauts de sept
mètres doit son existence à une
habitante du village
elise inversin lors d'un incendie en
l'an 2000 elle demande aux pompiers de
sauver son arbre avant même de sauver sa
propre maison mangeant l' elysée le
pistachier sont devenus des stars
le symbole de la protection forestière
en corse
bonjour bonjour alors il dit
racontez nous l'histoire de cet arbre il
a été menacé le 7 juillet de bill le feu
on voit encore les traces d'ailleurs
était à quelques mètres de l'arbre ma
maison risqué mais lorsque les pompiers
sont arrivés
j'ai demandé quand même qui sauvent
larmes en priorité parce que je pense
que ce millier d'années ce que
représente cet arbre il était il valait
mieux le sauver lui pour les générations
à venir que ma maison qu'on peut ouvrir
construire qu'est-ce qu'il vous apporte
aujourd'hui cet arbre du réconfort une
protection une sagesse les bruits
extérieurs l'ambiance est totalement
différente sous cet arbre
ce 7 juillet 2000 les flammes menacent
et parole des pompiers
c'était la première fois qu'il entendait
ça
madame inversin nous a dit je préfère
sauver l'arbre que le sauver ma maison
en trente ans de carrière sa première
fois que j'entends quand vous avez su me
sauver un arbre ils n'ont pas c'est bien
mais s'il existe encore c'est grâce à
elle
voilà
oh
à quelques kilomètres de là en bordure
de mer la forêt de pin et à 450 hectares
de pins main dans la main le maire de la
commune et les agents de l'eau nf tente
de protéger cette forêt d'un autre
danger car cette pinède est classé est
aujourd'hui dévasté en cause un petit
insecte d'à peine 2 mm le match caucus
mieux connu sous le nom de cochenilles
alors la colonie du pin maritime
et particulière c'est à dire que en fait
les larves se nourrissent de la sève de
l'arbre et leur nombre est tellement
important que ils affaiblissent
considérablement l'arbre alors en
définitive là on va être affaiblie mais
ne va pas directement forcément mourir
de la cochenille mais par contre la
cochenille facilite la pénétration nos
travailleurs qui attaquent donc l'arbre
et qui vont les faire mourir en deuxième
temps la forêt est devenu un véritable
laboratoire lohan f a introduit un
insecte une petite punaise d'origine
corse pour lutter contre la colonie
c'est un prédateur
c'est ce qu'on appelle une lutte
biologique dire qu'en fait la punaise
ainsi que la larve de la punaise vont se
nourrir des larmes et des femelles de la
cochenille est-ce que vous pouvez nous
montrer un des pièges que vous avez
installé pour voir si l'arbre est
infecté